[Música]
llegó el momento de directo Ahí vamos
hasta quito con nuestro corresponsal
Gustavo Ortega para conocer detalles
sobre un escándalo que sacude al
gobierno ecuatoriano personas cercanas
al presidente Guillermo lasso entre
ellas su cuñado son señaladas de hacer
parte de un supuesto entramado de
corrupción en las empresas públicas del
sector eléctrico lasso por su parte
descartó que la corrupción se haya
filtrado en su gobierno Gustavo muy
buenas noches cuéntenos En qué consiste
el escándalo y Qué efectos Podría tener
en el gobierno a propósito de las
próximas elecciones
Sí buenas noches un escándalo que señala
al cuñado el presidente de la república
Danilo Carrera y de liderar una presunta
estructura de corrupción para favorecer
contratos públicos a través de El
sobornos De igual forma también se le
señala de Designar ministros en el
sector eléctrico esto ha tenido
denuncias en el Ecuador durante dos
semanas El Ejecutivo nacional ha
demorado mucho tiempo en responder Pero
ha sido poco a poco con declaraciones
contradictorias cuando el presidente de
la república Guillermo lasso ha emitido
reacciones y acciones luego de ciertos
audios que se han venido filtrando que
involucran ahí señalan a Hernán Luque
quien era el ex director de la empresa
pública coordinadora de todas las
empresas públicas de este país y a
Danilo Carrera su cuñado pero
posteriormente El Ejecutivo nacional ha
venido tomando acciones como solicitar
la renuncia de todos los directivos de
las empresas públicas del Ecuador pedido
también la captura de Hernán Luque Pero
estas dos personas fueron designadas por
el presidente de la república porque
fueron
sus compañeros durante el banco de
Guayaquil durante muchos años pero el
presidente de la república lo ha negado
en todo momento pero paralelamente
también se han conocido otros informes
de organizaciones del Estado Pero cómo
podría influir bueno Esto podría ser
mucho más competitivo y estrecho los
resultados de la próxima consulta del
reforma constitucional que se realizará
en este país el cinco de febrero y
también podría minar un poco la
credibilidad pero El Ejecutivo nacional
ha realizado una campaña para separar
así lo que ha sido la campaña electoral
separándola de el presidente Guillermo
lasso que en este momento maneja una
aprobación aproximada de 25 y 30 por
ciento Gustavo paralelamente se conoció
de la renuncia del ex secretario
anticorrupción porque ha renunciado y
qué relación tiene esto con el escándalo
bueno el ex secretario hoy ex secretario
anticorrupción Luis verdes Soto había
sido una organización criada por el
ejecutivo nacional se le había pedido
también realizar un informe para
determinar si había corrupción tal y
como se han conocido algunas denuncias
específicamente Él presentó un informe
su primer informe sería el primer
informe que realiza esta institución y
efectivamente
se acercó al ejecutivo nacional
específicamente llegó a la presidencia
de la república donde presentó este
informe y presentó su carta de renuncia
porque en su informe él reconoce que
existe
monopolio corrupción en cuanto al sector
eléctrico el sector petrolero donde sí
estarían recibiendo algunos beneficios
que vienen por parte de cuotas
provenientes de altos funcionarios del
ejecutivo nacional y paralelamente
también la fiscalía general del estado
ya convoca a Danilo Carrera y esto ha
vibrado también investigaciones por
parte de la asamblea nacional a
investigar esta
presunta red de corrupción por parte del
ejecutivo nacional pero podría minar
también el entorno en el país y luego
que la asamblea nacional va a emitir un
informe luego de la Reforma
constitucional luego del cinco de
febrero tiene 30 días para hacerlo y De
igual forma también se estaría emitiendo
un informe por parte de los movimientos
indígenas que no están conforme con la
política del ejecutivo nacional
específicamente en la política minera